el comandante Max va camino a comprobar
que todo esté bien en las posiciones que
tiene su mando este es el lugar donde
viven y de allí se dirigen al punto de
observación las temperaturas que ya
bajan de Cero y lo congelan todo han
traído nuevos retos en el frente de
toresc en el don vast donde las fuerzas
ucranianas y rusas están a pocos metros
de distancia
ahora ahora todo parece normal pero Hace
media hora esto era el infierno todo el
mundo estaba escondido en sus trincheras
la posición estaba bajo el cuidado de
hombres que como Max se alistaron como
voluntarios después de la invasión rusa
el 24 de febrero
en invierno viven aquí por periodos que
se extienden hasta tres semanas
en mi opinión creo que si estábamos
preparados para estas condiciones
[Música]
porque nosotros somos voluntarios y
estamos listos para todo
las dificultades actuales en las que
todavía se ultiman detalles para tener
todo listo para el invierno no se
comparan con lo que soportaron al
comienzo de la Guerra el ejército
ucraniano no estaba preparado para
recibir tantos voluntarios
hay ciertas dificultades y asuntos por
resolver Porque algunos hombres tienen
que estar de servicio en el frente y
usar su ropa invernal personal debajo de
sus uniformes eso ciertamente crea
ciertos inconvenientes
el barro que cubrió esas trincheras en
otoño se ha secado Pero esto también
crea oportunidades para el enemigo
cuando hay barro en el piso está
resbaladizo y hay posibilidades de
caerse porque en la oscuridad no vemos
nada y nos movemos sin linterna para mí
el clima actual es más difícil porque
cuando el clima es más templado hay
nubes y llueve Entonces no hay drones
alrededor como consecuencia de la niebla
Así que lo que hago es ponerme los
zapatos y salir muchos has hablado de
que los frentes de batalla pueden
detenerse durante el invierno cuando el
barro se congele y las temperaturas
bajen a menos 20 bajo cero pero aquí
dicen que eso es un mito de guerra que
cuando se les ordena atacar no hay
condición climática que valga